ciao ciao ciao ciao
ciao sto vincendo Oh
sì tira tira
Mario bit adesso sei mia No oggi
videogiochi nella vita reale E ora siamo
nel videogioco
di
Pokémon andiamo a catturarli tutti
via Ehi il Pokédex mi ha detto che c'è
un Pokémon qua nelle vicinanze Vediamo
Dov'è presto seguiamolo dove sarà in
genere i Pokémon spuntano nell'erba alta
e noi siamo nell'erba quindi dovrebbe
essere qua nelle vicinanze Qual è il
vostro Pokémon preferito scrivetelo giù
nei commenti
Io spero di trovare un Pokémon di tipo
fuoco i miei preferiti Sì guarda c'è un
Pokémon lì pik pik pik è un Pikachu
Prova a prenderlo Sì catturi
[Musica]
amolo pica pica Oh no l'ho mancato provo
io a catturarlo bravaa
Vai
P No non si curale questo P è davvero
difficile da prendere è anche scappato
andiamo a prenderlo rinc corriam
solo P
PCA Ma dove sarà finito Pikachu non lo
vedo il pokedex mi dice che è di
là guarda lì Guarda Eccolo piccio è lì
proviamo a catturarlo adesso che è
girato di spalle S
pù Ops mi sa ho esagerato un pochino
questa volta E va bene Diventerò il
vostro Pokémon però non entrerò mai in
quella
sfera Beh almeno ne valta la pena
rimanere folgorati Sì abbiamo preso il
primo Pokémon
Che bello è il nostro primo Pokémon e
sono uno dei tanti che cattureremo io
voglio completare il Pokédex e catturare
tutti i Pokémon di canto sì e
cattureremo tutti gli altri Pokémon È
vero ci aiuterai Dove sono gli altri
tuoi amici io non ne ho idea come non ne
hai idea Aspetta però io ho una domanda
io non pensavo che i Pokémon
parlassero è vero è proprio strano Certo
che parliamo e visto che ora voi siete
nel nostro mondo di Pokémon riuscite a
capirci Ma è bellissimo questo quindi
Diventerete i nostri migliori amici ma
ora cerchiamo degli altri Pokémon presto
devo completare il pokedex e il pokedex
dice che c'è un Pokémon qua nelle
vicinanze Davvero E
dov'è baoba
Bob ma quello è un Bulbasaur Sì ma noi
abbiamo Pikachu qui possiamo utilizzare
Pikachu per indebolirlo così riusciremo
a catturarlo molto più
facilmente Vai Pikachu scelgo te vai
Pikachu usa tuono ricevuto
[Musica]
P Ora tocca a me mi avete fatto
arrabbiare perciò io uso Oh no sto
attaccando Pikachu foglia
Lama Wow mi ha fatto solletico la mossa
non è molto efficace su Pikachu Sì tocca
a te Pikachu usa fascino Ok perfetto
Userò la mossa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
fascino Oh Pikachu Ma sei
bellissima Ma perché siamo qua a locare
noi dovremmo diventare amicissimi super
per migliori amici forse anche più di
migliori amici vedi che tu sei
bellissimo anche io son bellissima siamo
perfetti insieme
Ah funziona
sempre questo è il momento perfetto per
catturare Bulbasaur Sì
via Sì abbiamo catturato il nostro
secondo Pokémon Bulbasaur
Missione compiuta grazie a me bravissimo
Pikachu e ora andiamo subito a cercare
altri Pokémon voglio catturarli tutti S
andiamo
Andiamo bene bene bene chi abbiamo qui
qualcuno sta prendendo i nostri Pokémon
già e e Voi chi siete Pica Io sono Billy
e io sono Vicky e insieme siamo il Team
Rocket pronti a partire alla velocità
della luce Oh no è il Team Rocket sono i
cattivi del mondo dei Pokémon tranquilli
Se le cose si dovessero mettere male vi
difenderò io come vi permettete di
catturare i nostri Pokémon come vi
permettete Adesso ve li rubiamo ma non
sono i vostri Pokémon erano Pokémon
liberi non è vero tutti i Pokémon sono
di nostra proprietà cattureremo tutti i
Pokémon e conquisteremo il mondo perché
noi siamo il Team Rocket tanto non ci
fate paura
Andiamocene presto Andiamocene
Dai ho
paura visto che non volete consegnarci i
vostri Pokémon charmender scelgo te
sì oh no hanno iniziato una lotta adesso
non possiamo più
scappare Bulbasaur scelgo
te Bulbasaur
un Pokémon di tipo erba Che stupidi
charmender usa fuoco
bomba
[Musica]
charm povero Bulbasaur Oh no Ma come non
lo sapevate che i Pokémon di tipo erba
sono deboli con quelli di tipo fuoco
ah povero Bulbasaur torno Bulbasaur
Oh no ma allora ci serve un Pokémon di
tipo Acqua Mi è venuta un'idea però lo
vado a cercare così lo sconfiggeremo
arrivo subito ciao Ma Vitale è scappato
ora non ci resta che contare su Pikachu
Speriamo che Pikachu riesca a
sconfiggere questo charmender Pikachu
Tocca a te adesso vai usa fulm sguardo
Pikachu
si sente
debole Oh no il fulm sguardo gli ha
abbassato la difesa così potrebbe anche
batterci Oh charmender si sente
[Applauso]
forte Ehi ma charmender si sta evolvendo
ma è
fantastico ma è fantastico
ora siamo potentissimi abbiamo
finalmente un Charizard è uno dei
Pokémon più forti in assoluto sono
fortissimo vi conviene arrendervi e
consegnarci tutti i vostri Pokémon no
noi non ci arrenderemo mai Pikachu usa
suono shock
Pikachu quel colpo non ha fatto quasi
niente al nostro Charizard e adesso
Charizard la mossa finale USA
lanciafiamme
Sì la mossa suono shock di Pikachu ha
paralizzato Charizard Questo è il
momento giusto Pikachu usa tuono
Pikachu Oh no Oh
no Ma com'è possibile il nostro
Charizard ha perso Oh no cianno
sconfitti la prossima volta non accadrà
e non accadrà Perché la prossima volta
ve li ruberemo tutti Pokémon
Pica ciao ciao ciao ciao
ciao bravissimo Pikachu bravissimi mi
sono perso qualcosa ma tu non stavi
andando a catturare i Pokémon di tipo
d'acqua Ah ecco che cosa dovevo fare Mi
ero dimenticato Vitale sempre il solito
ma adesso Passiamo subito al prossimo
videogioco 3 2 1
via siamo in Super Mario nella vita
reale e dovremo superare una serie di
Challenge Io sono Daisy e la prima
Challenge è la corsa col tacco vediamo
chi vincerà in questa Challenge nel
primo abbiamo Maria la sorella di Mario
Poi abbiamo la principessa pe e
Luigi io siete pronti a iniziare la
prima
Challenge 3 2 1
via Aiuto Aiuto Mi hanno superato Sì sto
vincendo
sì oh no è caduta Maria è
caduta Fammi passare Fammi passare ho
detto Aiuto stavo vincendo stavo
vincendo io Sì sì sto vincendo Sì ho
vinto vieni
qua Sì ho vinto Che bello Seo arrivata
prima Sono arrivata seconda certo non
sono prima però è un buon risultato
Brava Pis
sono arrivato ultimo e sono arrivato
rotolando Perché sono
caduto Mi dispiace che non abbia vinto
Luigi però Pach è stata molto brava Ora
tocca a noi sì andiamo subito ai punti
di partenza Spero di riuscire a vincere
[Musica]
Go
ho preso i sacchi grazie Todd Grazie Tod
e ora iniziamo il nostro round io Daisy
io Mario e io sono
3 2 1
via vai
Mario Vai C'è qualcosa di strano nel mio
tacco Vai Mario Vai Mario Fetto
fastidioso lasciami arriverò io primo ci
arriverò
io no Mario Ma che cos'è c'è qualcosa
che mi dà fastidio dentro questo
sacco
ah
che schifo che schifo che schifo Ahia mi
hai fatto male al Fungo
ah ah eh Che cos'è questo eh Mamma mia
che
dolore che schifo Quanto è brutto mamma
mia no noi non abbiamo superato la
Challenge perché qualcuno ci ha fatto
uno scherzo ma chi sarà stato ma questa
Challenge la vince la principessa Peach
Che bello passiamo ora alla seconda
Challenge seconda Challenge tiro alla
fune siamo divisi in due squadre e
dovremo sfidarci Chi riesce a tirare i
gune verso te e bere la squadra
avversaria vincerà la Challenge ma ora
iniziamo
subito
[Musica]
Dai ce la possiamo
fare
ragazzi forte più forte
[Musica]
vai sued
stico Ma che cosa è successo Non lo so
Maria è caduta Non lo so quanto riuscirò
a resistere Ho un'idea Luigi prendi uno
dei tuoi funghetti è
[Musica]
vero
[Applauso]
app Ah com'è possibile C eravamo i più
forti no dovevamo vincere noi per tutti
i funghetti che cosa è successo terza
Challenge la Challenge delle Mystery
box in questa Challenge ci sono varie
Mystery box nascoste e L'obiettivo è
trovare le Mystery box con dentro le
monete d'oro invece altre Mystery box
avranno detto dentro degli scherzetti
chi trova più monete d'oro vince Ma voi
avete cliccato mi piace cliccate subito
mi piace qua sotto e l'ultima cifra del
vostro mi piace corrisponde a un
personaggio di Super Mario che vedete
qua a fianco che personaggio vi è
capitato e adesso che inizi la
[Applauso]
Challenge
Che bella che è questa pianta la devo
assolutamente regalare alla mia
fidanzata
Daisy Ma questa pianta mi ha morzo
Luis che cosa stai facendo Eh volevo
prendere questa pianta per regalartelo
allontanati allontanati morde Ma come
non la conosci questa è la pianta
carnivora di Super
Mario hai trovato una delle Mystery box
sì l'ho trovato io l'ho trovato io qua
dietro
vediamo subito che cosa c'è dentro che
ci siano le monete non lo scherzetto
vediamo la
moneta abbiamo collezionato la nostra
prima moneta è una squadra
fantastica Peach Ma quanto sei bella mia
cara Peach troverò tutte le monete solo
per te che schifo Mario mi hai fatto
venire il vomito con questa
cantilena sorellina lascia in pace Vai a
cercare le scatole tu ne ho appena
trovata una Ecco
qua Grazie sorellina principessa P
Questa è da parte mia oh Grazie Mario
Sei troppo
gentile che schifo
ma sembra moccio di
yosi Che
schifo Mario i tuoi regali sono sempre
così Schifosi ma non è colpa mia quella
scatola me l'ha data Maria Mario Non
provare a dare la colpa a me è una
scatola misteriosa Non sapevo che cosa
c'era dentro Adesso basta mi sono offesa
me ne vado è tutta colpa tua Maria basta
ora Cerca delle scatole da
sola Ah finalmente sono libera di
cercare le scatole da sola senza quel
romp
scatole una scat è la mia occasione per
prenderla Peach Daisy e veramente
stavamo per prendere noi questa scatola
no la stavo prendendo Io sono arrivata
prima io ma noni l'abbiamo vista prima
non mi interessa l'ho presa prima io
vedi Ce l'ho in mano Aspetta tu hai già
preso una delle scatole Sì ma era un
brutto scherzetto di Mario dentro c'era
Muccio di Yoshi Che schifo Perciò questa
è mia Moccia di Yoshi Vabbè dai siccome
noi abbiamo già preso una scatola con
delle monete la lasciamo a te però se
c'è del cibo per favore Condividilo con
me Almeno ma non c'è il cibo in queste
Mystery box e magari c'è qualcosa di
buono che ne sai è Mystery no ci sono
solo o le monete o uno scherzetto e
speriamo che ci siano le monete non uno
scherzetto Spero che ci sia almeno un
cioccolatino
vediamo C'è una monetina
Evviva cioè anche se non l'abbiamo presa
noi Sono contenta per te Peach Beh è la
mia prima quindi meno male e ora andiamo
a cercare le altre io Ciao dopo ciao
Uffa Non c'è niente ho cercato da tutte
le parti e non ho trovato nulla Ho
un'idea qua non c'è
niente qua
neanche e qua lo stesso Non c'è niente
da nessuna parte dove posso
cercare idea dietro la porta
ah ah cosa stai facendo No tu che cosa
stai facendo niente perché ti sembra
strano che non sto facendo niente dietro
a una porta Beh Sinceramente sì E va
bene te lo dico credo che qui ci sia una
Mystery box però non riesco ad aprirla
CR ne diresti di aiutarmi e va bene ma
ha una condizione se lì dentro c'è
qualcosa il premio lo dividiamo Certo
certo dai iniziamo Aiutami vedo ok Al
mio tre tiriamo Vai 1 2
uh lo sapevo Avevo ragione c'era
qualcosa Ok apriamo questa
scatola Sì però aprirla
cioè che
[Musica]
[Applauso]
schifo c'è
nessuno ho visto che tutti sono
impazziti per queste Mystery box e
chissà cosa c'è di bello dentro monete
d'oro cibo la mia adorata Peach no Peach
non può stare dentro una scatolina è il
momento di cercare qualche
[Musica]
premio ne ho già trovata
una Allora
apriamolo che cosa è che
schif Che schifo no Che
puzza che schifo è un piede puzzolente e
si sa che noi tartarughe le odiamo i
piedi puzzolenti
[Musica]
Ecco e ma
oh Eccola finalmente Guarda brilla di
una luce brillante questo è sicuramente
un premio anzi
aspetta
Sì non puzza di
piedi
le mie monete
d'oro Che schifo sono lombrichi
Fermi Che schifo che Challenge Che
brutta
Challenge non va bene neanche una non è
possibile ma questa è un'altra scatola
ma è
incredibile Ok sono sicuro che adesso
troverò qual cosa di
bello No questo è il moccio di Yoshi Che
schifo
Dammela l'ho
presa l'ho presa
izie Ho preso l'ultima moneta ma qu
monete avete preso solo una noi ne
abbiamo prese due e tu
Io due e tu Maria quante ne abbiamo
prese quante ne abbiamo prese Forse tre
Sì tre ma ancora la Challenge non è
finita credo che ci siano ancora altre
Mystery box da trovare CTO Sì andiamo a
cercarne altre allora no C di là L'ho
presa l'ho presa Ioa Peach siamo amiche
dai Dobbiamo l'ho presa io Vediamo un
po' cosa c'è dentro speriamo sia una
moneta Sì una moneta e Sio a due così
folata lo
so Guardatela Questa è l'ultima Mystery
box ed è piena di monete è tutta vostra
prendetela eh c'ha fregati sono
disgustosi bit adesso sei Mi
no E voi bruti stupidi vi ho
fregato Bowser ha rapito Pach la M amata
Bowser te lo farò pagare a parola di
idraulico dobbiamo trovare Peach dove
l'avrà portata può essere che l'abbia
portata nel suo castello giusto Uniamo
le forze allora e andiamo cercarla
Uniamo le forze andiamo a salvare i PRIT
presto
andiamo
P l' avuto bower Preparati perché siamo
qua per sconfiggerli e per liberare la
principessa Peach Esatto ora ti
sconfiggiamo sono arrivati e credete che
potete liberare la principessa Peach ma
ormai lei è via e non ce la farete mai a
liberarla liberatevi da questa tartaruga
puzzolente per favore Vabbè sono un po'
puzzolente Allora lo userò come
arma chea abbassa quelle scelle che
schifo ma è fortissimo non si lava da
mesi almeno Mettiti il deodorante presto
colpi amolo subito prima di svenire
orelo Beccati questo pause
No adesso te lo faccio vedere
io ecco
qua è arrivato il momento della mia
mossa
finale
[Musica]
io forza Mario Vai
Mario Mario No no noi
no
brav fortisimo Vai a liberare la
principessa Peach sto Oh grazie Questo
te lo sei proprio meritato solo vissimo
è come se avesse VTO bene li V tutti
assieme
[Applauso]
sì Peach ho una cosa per te ecco qua
Grazie la mia
Corona Sì abbiamo vinto questa Challenge
tutti insieme Abbiamo sconfitto il
cattivo
bower ci vediamo al prossimo video
Ciao